What treatments do you suggest for tumors that have broken through the skin? Well, it depends on the tumor.
So, typically, topical things like black sap are really good for certain types of cancer.
Specifically, black sap was originally formulated for skin cancers and most commonly for melanoma.
Though we have people with squamous cell cancer that use it, you really don't want to use black sap on basal cell cancer, but for squamous cell and melanoma.
We had people use black sap for breast cancers that have broken through the surface and some other different cancers that have broken through the surface.
There's just needs to be a lot of precaution taken and it's difficult to oversee the use of black sap with a person because black sap can be extremely caustic.
And it can draw cancer really strongly, which is a good thing, but the bad thing is that you really need somebody local to help support you to be able to actually visualize it in person.
And look at it, making sure that it's drawing the way we want it to draw and such.
So, we do have some people with breast cancer that are using black sap, but most of them have a local person that they're working with as well, so it's not just us that they're working with.
Some other cancers that have broken through the surface that are very large, you really can't use black sap black sap is typically recommended or no more than a dime or a quarter size in the cancer.
Cancer, so it's about three centimeter of cancer and it's greatest, it can cause a lot of pain, you might be paying medications and so on issues with it, so we don't recommend that, but you can certainly use a different curcumin cream, there's just bunch of different stuff that you can try on a tumor that's broken through the surface.
There's a lot of patients that are trying different things, so that's what we recommend because every cancer is different and you're going to react differently.